je met pas sur le même plan la critique
des médias de bourdieu et d'halimi jeu
c'est de montrer au contraire qu' il ya
un malentendu
alors assez les deux livres sur la
télévision et les nouveaux chiens de
garde sont publiés dans la même
collection celle de bourdieu
mais on a d'un côté une critique
structurelle des médias ou bourdieu met
en évidence comment des gens qui croient
être opposés ont des formes de
socialisation
un inconscient de classe proches parmi
les journalistes et donc c'est ce qu'il
appelle connivence c'est à dire c'est
une mise en rapport mais qui n'est pas
consciente et chez halimi cette vision
de la connivence minutes vers le
copinage et donc vers la manipulation et
est donc vers la conspiration est donc
une grande partie de la critique
manichéenne des médias tels qu la plume
en mettre en place dans le monde
diplomatique ou dans des journaux comme
plpl ou le plan b à un moment donné va
mettre l'accent sur une dimension
simplement manipulatoire et d'une
certaine façon va faire oublier les la
structure des rapports sociaux les
rapports de classe les logiques du
capitalisme les rapports de domination
raciale les rapports de domination
masculine et cetera au profit d'une
vision en août superficiel en terme de
manipulation et tout ça ça va nourrir ce
que j'appelle l'hyper criticisme
contemporain c'est à dire quelque chose
qui est très critique qu'on voit sur
internet et sur les réseaux sociaux qui
paraît très critique très proche de
cette critique radicale de la société
capitaliste mais en fait qu'une critique
superficielle qu'une critique que de ce
qu'ils appelaient le politiquement
correct et qui va insister sur les
manipulations consciente et les complots
et y en a dix ans une destruction de de
la critique par elle même
[Musique]